it feels like every day the world is
shifting beneath our feet but in order
to understand where we're headed we must
first understand where we've been there
have been two major alliances that have
basically run the world for the last few
decades the first is between china and
america known as chimerica and the
second is between europe and russia
known as your russia while these two
alliances were different they were
separate they had a lot of similarities
they ultimately were built on trust
according to zoltan over at credit
suisse he states both unions were a
heavenly match the eu paid euros for
cheap russian gas the u.s paid u.s
dollars for cheap chinese imports in
russia and china dutifully recycled
their earnings into g7 claims all sides
were entangled commercially as well as
financially and as the old wisdom goes
if we trade everyone benefits and so we
won't fight
but like in any marriage that's true
only if there is harmony harmony is
built on trust and occasional
disagreements can only be resolved
peacefully provided there is trust
but when trust is gone everything is
gone which is the scary conclusion from
dale copeland's book economic
interdependence and war now ultimately
countries get along and have peace
because they either have the greed of
future prophets or the fear of future
ruin and what we have seen in both of
the major alliances on the geopolitical
chess board is that they work together
and there was globalization but now it
seems that due to u.s sanctions supply
chain disruptions covet 19 and much more
it feels like we are headed towards a
time of deglobalization
all of a sudden there are now many
countries that are coming together that
have been sanctioned by the united
states and they are beginning to build a
brand new alliance these countries
include turkey russia iran china and
north korea now we are seeing these
countries carrying out military
exercises together beginning to increase
their bilateral trade and their
leadership appears to be much more
sympathetic to each other on the public
stage but here is the problem if this
new unlikely alliance is any way
successful that will lead to a
multi-polar world that is actually the
theme of deglobalization when we look
back at history we know that
globalization that led to a low
inflation environment that allowed the
united states of america to export qe
around the world
but if we transition from a simple two
alliance driven world order to this
multi-polar world with the unlikely
alliance of countries that have been
sanctioned by the united states coming
together and pushing back that will
likely move from a low inflation
environment
to a high inflation crisis
we already see high inflation both in
the united states and on the
international stage we see multiple
countries dealing with double-digit
inflation regardless of whether you
think it's driven by undisciplined
monetary and fiscal policy supply chain
disruptions the pandemic or just poor
decision making we now know that these
countries that are coming together and
working in a way that they previously
have not
that is causing major major issues if
you even look at something like taiwan
and china you can see that now this
global supply chain that was built on
efficiency and low-cost labor
is now coming under threat
because a global supply chain is only
efficient and it is only valuable if it
actually is able to deliver you supplies
materials and goods and services but if
we now move to this multi-polar world
that may not be the case anymore we now
have to ask ourselves is the united
states still going to be able to
leverage a global supply chain a global
manufacturing base
are we going to be competitive in the
21st century if we continue to operate
with the belief that there will only be
two major alliances on the geopolitical
chessboard i don't know if we can say
that anymore and it appears that that
ground that is shifting underneath our
feet
is actually leading more and more
towards the multipolar world what that
means here in america is that we are
going to have to get to work we are
going to have to reassure manufacturing
we're going to have to bring our supply
chains back within our borders
this is the super bowl for american
entrepreneurs we have massive problems
laying in front of us and we need people
who have the ability to dream
and who have the courage and the
conviction to act these individuals are
going to have to help solve some of
these problems because if the united
states of america wants to stay at the
forefront of economic progress end of
freedom
we no longer are going to be able to
rely on those past alliances now as the
world shifts is really a time where the
people in the arena are going to have
the most impact there are plenty of
talking heads there are plenty of people
writing opinion pieces but ultimately
the future of the world order will boil
down to who can build the solutions
who can strategically place themselves
in a position to create and capture
value and who
is willing to put themselves in a
position to make bold bets and reap the
rewards over the coming decades the
world is changing and we must understand
where we used to be
in order to get a better sense of where
we're going no one can predict the
future but what we do know is that
change is happening
and when change happens
opportunity lies ahead hey you did you
like this video great make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time